and uh i mean as eric talks about
uh on the science side of things i mean
i said
uh like at mit especially in the machine
learning field
there's a natural institutional
resistance to the weird
it's very as they talk about it's it's
difficult to hire weird faculty for
example
correct you want to hire you want to
hire and give tenure to people that are
safe
and not weird and that's one of the
concerns is like it seems like the weird
people are the ones that push the
science forward usually
right and so like how do you how do you
balance the two it's not obvious
because there's another area where eric
and i disagree as i
interpret him he thinks academia is
totally bankrupt yeah
and i think it's only partially bankrupt
how do we fix it because i i'm with you
i'm i'm bullish on academia
you need up-and-coming schools that end
up better than where they started off
and mit
was once one of them yes now they're not
in every area in some areas they have
become the problem
yeah you chicago you wouldn't call it up
and coming but it's still different
and that's great let's hope they managed
to keep it that way
uh the biggest problem to me is the rank
absurd conformism
at kind of second-tier schools maybe in
the top 40 but not in the top dozen
that are just trying to be like a junior
mit but it's mediocre and copycat
and they're the most dogmatic enforcers
of weirdness that like
harvard is more open than those
second-tier schools
and those second-tier schools are pretty
good typically right yeah
but the mediocrity is enforced there
correct
very strictly and the homogenization
pressures
look try you know climb their rankings
by another three places
and be a little closer to mit though
you'll never touch them yeah that to me
is very harmful
and you'd rather they be more like
chicago more like caltech
or the older caltech all the more like
pick some model
be weird in it you might fail that's
socially better
yeah but so the problem with mit for
example
is the mediocrity is really
enforced on the junior faculty yeah so
like the people that are allowed to be
weird
or actually they just don't even ask for
permissions anymore are more senior
faculty
and that's good of course but you want
the weird young people
uh you know i find to you know this
podcast i like talking to
tech people and i find the young faculty
to be really boring
they are they're the most boring of
faculty their work
is interesting technically technically
but just the the the passion
they are drudges
and it's some of them sneak by like you
have like the max tag mark
young version of max tegmark who knows
how to play the role of boring and
and fitting in and on the side he does
the weird [ __ ]
but they're not they're far and few in
between which i
i'd love to figure out a way to shake up
that system because
as you look at mit's broad institute
right in biomedical it's been a huge hit
yeah i'm not privy to their internal
doings but i suspect they
support weird more than the formal
departments do
at the junior level yes that's probably
true yeah i don't know what
whatever they're doing it's working but
uh
we need to figure it out because i think
the best ideas still do come from the
uh so forget my apologies but for the
humanities side of things i don't
i don't know anything about but the
engineering and the science side i think
there's so many amazing ideas that are
still coming from universities
it's not true that you don't know
anything about the humanities you're
doing the humanities right now
we're talking about people there are no
numbers put on a blackboard
right there's no hypothesis testing per
se no yes
you have however many subscribers to
your podcast
all listening to you on the humanities
every
whatever your frequency is there i'm not
in the department of the humanities
that's why
it's innovative they have very different
conversations
there's the number of emails i get about
listen i i really deeply respect
diversity
and the and the the full scope of what
diversity means and also the more narrow
scope of different races and genders and
so on it's a really important topic
but there's a disproportionate number of
emails i'm getting
about meetings and discussions and
that just kind of is overwhelming i
don't get enough emails from people
like a meeting about uh why are all your
ideas bad
let's let's uh for example let me call
out mit why don't we do
more uh why don't we kick stanford's ass
or google's ass more importantly in deep
learning and machine learning and ai
research
what uh cell for example used to be a
laboratory
is a laboratory for artificial
intelligence research
and why is that not the the beacon
of what of greatness
in artificial intelligence let's have
those meetings as well
diversity talk has oddly become this new
mechanism for enforcing conformity
yes exactly and right so it's almost
like this conformity mechanism finds
the hot new topic to use to enforce
further conformity exactly
oh boy i still have hope i remain
optimistic
the humanities have innovated through
podcasts including yours and mine
yeah and they're alive and well all the
bad talk you hear about the humanities
in universities
there's been this huge enron of
innovation on the internet yeah and it's
amazing you're right
i never thought i mean this is
humanities
this this podcast i've been speaking
pros all one's life and didn't know it
right
uh yeah i am actually part of the
humanities department at mit now
i didn't not realize this and i i will
fully embrace it from this moment on
look you have this thing the media lab
i'm sure you know about it done some
excellent things done a lot of very
bogus things
but you're out competing them you're
blowing them out of the water yeah
like you are them yeah i mean and i'm
talking to those folks and they
they're trying to well uh they're trying
to figure it out i mean they had their
issues with jeffrey epstein and so on
but outside of that
there's a i've actually gone through a
shift with this particular podcast for
example
where at first it was seen as a
one the very first it was seen as a
distraction
second it was a source of like almost
like a kind of jealousy
like the same kind of jealousy you feel
when junior faculty outshines the senior
faculty
and now it's more like oh okay this is a
thing
like we should do more of that we should
embrace this guy we should embrace this
thing
so there's a sense that podcasting and
whatever this is not it's just not the
podcasting
will drive some innovation within mit
within different universities
there's a sense that things are changing
it's just that universities lag behind
and
my hope is that you know they catch up
quickly
they they they they innovate in some way
that
goes along with the innovations of the
internet um
the internet will outrace them for a
long time maybe forever
well i mean but it's okay if they're as
long as they keep in yeah and we're both
in universities so we have multiple hats
on here yes we're speaking so yes
we can complain about the universities
that's like complaining about the
podcast
right yeah we be them
you